PEDRO ARELLANO: Hello,
everyone, and thank you
for joining me today.
This is Data
Leaders At The Helm.
And in this session,
we're going to take a look
at how technologies and
workplace environments are
evolving, and how these
changes are turning data
leaders into an emerging
force, and are placing them
in a unique position to
really chart a path forward
for their organizations.
My name is Pedro
Arellano, and I'm
Head of Product Marketing
for Looker at Google Cloud.
Those of you
familiar with Looker
may have noticed that
we have a new logo.
It's very exciting.
We are now part of Google Cloud.
Looker's mission
statement, which
is to empower people through
the smarter use of data,
actually aligns very, very
well with Google's mission
statement, which is all
about organizing the world's
information and
making it universally
accessible and useful.
Another thing that Looker and
Google Cloud share in common
is that we are absolutely
committed to investing
in multi-cloud.
And that's a common
theme that you
would hear throughout
the sessions this week.
Just a bit of quick context
about where the Looker
product stands today.
Today there are more
than 5,000 developers all
building on top of
the Looker platform.
We have more than 2,000
companies all over the world
using Looker, from the
largest retailers and banks,
all the way down to one
to two-person startups.
And something that will be
pretty central to today's
talk and other Looker sessions
you attend this week--
half of our customers
are using Looker
to work with data in a way that
goes beyond traditional BI.
Now, before we get
started, I do want
to take a moment to
state today's goals.
First, my goal is to--
hopefully you understand
that the value
of data within an organization
is no longer up for debate.
Everybody needs data,
and everybody's job
has the potential to
be improved with data.
Second, there are
three trends that we're
going to identify and
explore in this presentation,
and these trends will
help put into context
how we've arrived at
this particular moment
of such great
potential for data.
And finally, we want
you, as data leaders,
to significantly understand
that almost regardless
of your title, you're
now in a position
to really influence the
direction of your organization
like never before.
So hopefully this is
why you've decided
to join this session today,
and it will help you better
equip yourself with
knowledge and help
you grow as a data leader
in your organization,
and also to connect further
with the data community.
So let's get started.
Let's get right to the
heart of the presentation.
I'm going to start by
highlighting three trends that
are contributing to
the success of Looker,
and trends that we believe
every data professional should
be aware of to maximize
your own potential.
The first trend is that
everybody needs data,
and that everybody
at an organization
can benefit from it.
In fact, I would argue that more
so than everybody needs data,
everybody expects data.
So why is that?
Well, let's take a look at
this stat from an IDC research
paper.
It shows that the
world's data is
expected to reach 175
zettabytes by the year 2025.
And just to put that
figure in perspective,
if each gigabyte in a
zettabyte were a brick,
we would have enough
bricks to build the Great
Wall of China 258 times.
And that's just a
staggering figure.
It's a massive
explosion of data.
What exactly is
driving this growth?
What's driving this
demand for data?
Well, what's driving
this demand is
that the data-hungry workforce,
as we call it, has arrived.
Think about it-- today there
are all these job titles that
didn't even exist 10 years ago,
jobs whose entire purpose is
to work with data and deliver
data across an organization.
And there are so many
roles that simply
can't function without data--
quantitative marketers,
DevOps engineers,
data-driven product managers.
10 years ago you still needed
to convince your executive team
of how much data
matters, how important it
is to be able to push
the organization forward,
and how transformative
it can be.
But the demand for
data is now such
that it's created all of
these job titles around data.
You have digital
marketers who can
be way more effective on
managing their spend using
very innovative applications
like automated bots
that automatically increase
or decrease bids on online ads
depending on the
performance of those ads.
You have product managers who
can better understand product
usage, and they can
use that understanding
to know where they
need to invest time,
and where they need to
invest development efforts,
and also spot opportunities
for expansion.
But despite this growing demand
for data across organizations,
we still find that
66% of companies--
2/3 of companies-- are
still using spreadsheets
for the majority
of their analytics,
which begs the question,
is this the best way?
Are spreadsheets
really the best way
to reach people within an
organization using data?
Are the tools that
we're using today
the right ones to reach
this data-driven workforce,
or this data-hungry workforce?
And the market has clearly
answered this question,
and that leads us
to trend number 2.
Trend number 2 is that
SaaS business and consumer
applications are
absolutely exploding.
And yes, this is contributing
to the massive growth in data
volumes, but it's
also creating new ways
to reach people with data.
So think about it-- how
many SaaS applications
have you used just today?
Just doing a quick
count, I started my day
on Gmail and Google Calendar.
I used Google Chat
to message my team.
I reviewed my presentation
and my notes in Google Docs
and Google Slides.
I've used applications to
look at our customer CRM data.
I used another
application to understand
our marketing funnel.
So by the end of the
day, I'll probably
have used more than
20 SaaS applications.
And what's interesting is that
each of these applications
is actually a data application.
It's generating data.
It's crunching data.
It's feeding me
data in some way.
Now, to give you some
context, the Looker team--
we use more than 40
SaaS applications
to run our business, but
the average enterprise
uses over 1,000
SaaS applications,
and that number continues
to grow every year.
Now, as I said, all
these applications
are data applications.
They are data-powered products.
It's basically a user experience
built on top of rows of data,
and their goal is to reduce user
friction when accessing data
and when accessing insights,
and make the whole experience
with the data lot
better and a lot easier.
So I'll give you a
couple of examples.
If you're a digital
marketer, your job
is already made better, it's
enhanced, by using Google Ads.
If you're working
with CRM data, you're
probably using Salesforce.
Salesforce is an enormously
popular CRM system.
And these products are trying to
make data way more accessible,
to help people in
your organization
get their job done.
But it does come
with challenges,
because these products--
they're very good,
but they're typically very good
for one particular use case.
They're designed for a
specialized use case.
So for example, you
probably wouldn't
use Zendesk to analyze your
advertising performance,
in the same way
that you wouldn't
use Salesforce to track and
manage your help desk tickets.
So these applications are
already very powerful,
but that means that
they're also very isolated,
and you have to jump from
application to application
to really do your job.
And what that means is that
you end up missing insights,
and you end up
missing opportunities
that are only
uncovered when you're
able to connect the
data, which allows you
to see the complete picture.
So when every department gets
a specialized SaaS application
like this, it means
that you start
seeing islands of departmental
data start appearing.
The sales team, for example,
will use one set of apps.
They use Salesforce
and a few other apps.
Marketing will do
the same thing.
They'll use Google Ads.
They'll use Marketo
and something else.
The product team will use
yet another set of apps,
and so on and so forth.
Across the organization,
you see this happening.
The problem here is
that each department
has its own island of data.
They have their
own silo of data.
But they're all disconnected
from each other.
And they could all
potentially have
a different, and
even conflicting
understanding of
critical business metrics
that should, in theory, be
shared across the organization,
and everybody should have
a common understanding
about them.
So data professionals--
we refer to this
as an analytics
governance problem,
but it is a very big problem.
It's a bigger problem than
that, because it's also a value
problem, because the fundamental
value of business intelligence,
a fundamental belief that we all
share, is that connecting data
makes it way more valuable,
and that it's only
with connected data
that we get a better
understanding and a more
comprehensive view of how
a business really functions.
Now, this problem, I'm afraid,
is only going to get worse.
It's going to get
tougher to solve.
According to IDC, within
the next three years,
500 million new business
apps will be created.
So if we think that this
is a tough problem now,
if we think it's hard
to organize data now,
it's only going to get harder.
It's going to get
harder a lot faster.
So the question
is, what do we do?
Well, something has to change.
According to Forrester,
over 80% of structured data
isn't analyzed.
And that's really
unfortunate, because it
means that over time, we're
losing valuable insights,
and we're losing the opportunity
to benefit from connected data.
But fortunately, there is hope.
And that hope is
trend number 3--
data infrastructure
is rapidly evolving.
So data engineering technologies
have really come a long way.
They've changed dramatically
in the last few years,
and they've really raised the
level of analytics and insights
that are achievable.
If I think back at when
I started my career
more than 20 years
ago, the technologies
that were considered
the gold standard then
are so, so different
to what we have today.
The first set of
those technologies
is modern cloud databases--
databases like BigQuery,
like Snowflake, even some
of the AWS offerings.
These are bigger,
faster, cheaper databases
where you can store
massive amounts of data.
You can query the data
at a much lower cost.
You can do it at a much
higher level of performance
than these platforms
of years past.
But these databases are
also getting smarter.
You're seeing things
like augmented analytics,
machine learning, and other
technologies that automatically
generate insights and
are integrated directly
into the database.
The second thing
you're seeing is
that once you have your data
stored in a modern cloud
database, you can now take
a more modern approach
to integrating and
managing the data.
And this modern
approach doesn't depend
on physical data
extracts, and it
can transform data on the fly.
And it's called ELT.
ELT basically takes the
traditional idea of ETL
and flips it on its head.
It makes the
management of the data
ecosystem a lot simpler, a
lot more flexible, a lot more
agile.
And you're going to
find, with this approach,
that you'll need
fewer data extracts.
You'll be able to access
data in real time.
complete row-level data.
And your updates--
your data updates--
are going to be
simpler and run faster.
But here's the key--
what enables this
new ELT approach,
what makes it possible,
is the growing
importance of model data.
And what I mean by that
is the ability to use
or deploy a semantic model that
describes all of your company's
data, a semantic model that
defines all of your business
logic.
And with Looker,
you use a technology
that we call LookML for
your semantic modeling.
What's great about
LookML is that it's
a highly collaborative
technology,
and it allows tens or even
hundreds of data engineers
to work together on the
same semantic model.
And what this does is that it
enables real data teams, as
opposed to having
individuals off on their own
doing shadow IT.
So it's a very exciting time
to work in this industry.
These data engineering
technologies,
or these advancements in data
engineering technologies,
are really changing
our world and our lives
as data professionals,
and they're
allowing us to bring much
more data to the cloud.
They're making it
faster and easier
to deploy different
types of data.
And as I said, they really
allow your workforce
to work collaboratively
and at scale.
Now, let me share a glimpse of
how quickly some of these cloud
data technologies
are being adopted.
What you're seeing here is a
view across Looker's customer
base that shows the growth
of different database
technologies.
So you can see some of the
classic data-based technologies
like Postgres and MySQL, and
they're still being used.
But if you pay attention
to the modern platforms,
like BigQuery and
Snowflake, the growth
that we're seeing with
those technologies
is just absolutely remarkable.
So if part of your motivation
for attending this session
is that your
company's considering
making a transition or an
investment in a cloud database,
now is the time to do that.
Gartner says that within
the next three years,
75% of all databases
in existence
will be hosted in the cloud.
And one of the main reasons
for that phenomenon-- growth
of the cloud-- is the ability
to leverage and manage data
at the scale required today.
So with those three
trends in mind,
let's wrap up this
section with a description
of what we think success
with data looks like.
The first criteria is that
data needs to be complete,
and it needs to be trustworthy.
There needs to be
confidence in the data.
People need to be able to trust
the insights that your data
platform is delivering.
We talk to companies
all the time who
don't trust the data that
their platform is delivering
because there's no
consistent business
logic across the thousands
of workbooks or spreadsheets
or reports that are being
used by their employees,
so what happens is
that instead of having
productive conversations
about the data,
you end up arguing over
whose numbers are correct.
And in order to restore
that trust, what's needed
is a centralized and reusable
semantic modeling layer,
something like what Looker's
LookML technology provides
that allows everyone to work
with the same definition
of key business logic.
So there's never
ever any ambiguity
over what the data means.
There is only one
definition of customer.
calculation for profit.
There is only one definition
of revenue, for example.
And everybody is speaking
the same language.
The second criteria is that
data should be near real-time.
And that's really what
modern cloud databases
allow us to do today.
They make near real-time
insights a reality.
And think of how valuable this
is, really, for any industry.
But take retailers, for example.
Imagine if retailers
could optimize
their digital advertising
spend in real time
during the holiday
shopping season.
It's just massively valuable.
The third criteria is
that data should not just
have an analytical purpose.
It should also have an
operational purpose.
And this is a really big
departure from the way
that we've come to think
of data traditionally.
It means that the insights
that your data platform is
generating should have the
potential to trigger actions.
And the reason is that modern
business users don't just
want to understand the data.
They want to be able to use
data to get something done,
to take some kind of action.
What that means
is that we finally
have to actually go beyond
dashboards in the way
that we use data.
Data should feed other systems.
It should feed other machines to
help people get real work done,
to help drive the
business forward.
It should not be used just
to display on our report.
So let's take a look at a few
examples of how this actually
works in the real world.
The first example is a
company called SalesLoft.
SalesLoft is a prospecting
and customer engagement
platform based in Atlanta.
And their Customer Success
Team monitors customer health
scores.
And these scores
look at product usage
and alert the Customer Success
Team of any potential issues
early on.
Now, unfortunately,
this information
has to be manually monitored
and manually looked up in order
to catch low scores
before risking
a customer [? turning. ?]
What they've done is
now they've replaced
this manual system with
an automated system
that they've built using Looker.
So they combined Looker
with the SalesLoft platform
so that when a customer
health score drops
below a certain threshold, an
alert automatically notifies
the Customer Success
Manager of that problem,
and then automatically
triggers an email
within their engagement
platform to start
reengaging with that customer.
This is massively
valuable for SalesLoft.
It increases the relevance of
their customer communications.
It increases the impact of
And it ultimately creates a
better customer experience.
And notice how this use case
isn't about showing numbers
on a graph or on a
dashboard, but it's still
an immensely valuable
data-driven application.
And just how valuable?
Well, this application helps
SalesLoft preserve $1.2 million
in ARR in the first
four months alone.
Another example
is Car Next Door.
Car Next Door is a car-sharing
company in Australia.
The Car Next Door team
was already using Looker.
They were getting
value from Looker
across a number of
different areas--
optimizing marketing, delivering
faster support, more efficient
product development.
But then they used Looker in a
way that was pretty unexpected.
Last year, there were some
pretty severe hailstorms
that hit parts of Australia.
And these storms cost
really serious damage
to many of Car Next
Door's vehicles.
And of course, as
you can imagine,
this resulted in higher repair
costs, insurance, losses
from damaged vehicles that they
had to take out of service.
That also covered
potential new risks,
should something like
this happen again.
So in order to reduce future
downtime and future losses
and to be able to
continue delivering
an excellent
customer experience,
the Car Next Door team quickly
developed a new application
using Looker that would help
them prepare for future weather
events.
So what they do is
that they use Looker's
geospatial capabilities.
And that allows them
to identify cars
that are in locations that are
associated with weather events.
And in combination with
other technologies,
like Sediment and Braze, they
can send alerts to drivers
to help them get to safety.
So this is another
example of using data
in a way that does not involve
displaying it on a reporter
or on a dashboard, but it
does help Car Next Door
identify at-risk cars
and at-risk drivers.
And it improves the
reliability of the service
and it improves the
customer experience, too.
And all of this is
powered by Looker.
Finally, an example that
anybody in sales will relate to,
this is about Slack.
Slack has a product that they
built called Midas Touch.
The problem that the
Midas Touch tool solves
is that their sales reps were
spending many, many hours
every single week creating
customer slide decks.
So they were building
these decks by hand
by literally copying and pasting
content from their BI tool
into Google Slides.
This is very
time-consuming work.
It's very repetitive.
It's very prone to errors.
So of course, it's a perfect
candidate for automation.
So they envision the Midas
Touch tool-- excuse me--
at its core as integration
between Slack and Salesforce
and Looker and Google Slides.
And what the Midas
Touch tool does
is it allows the sales reps in
Slack to search for customers,
communicating with Salesforce.
And then it requests a set of
pre-populated, personalized
slides for that customer with
data that's pulled from Looker,
all without leaving Slack.
So this means that a sales rep
can generate a personalized
report for every single customer
and every single customer
meeting that they go into
with a single command.
As you can imagine,
it makes them
look like heroes in every
meeting that they go to.
And it's a really
interesting example
because it's such a
great story of how
data can be used from
multiple different departments
and can be brought
together in order
to massively amplify the
experience for every customer.
Now, these customer
examples show
how the three trends
that we reviewed earlier
are all converging to create
many great opportunities
for companies to really
build different kinds of data
experiences, and
for data leaders
to influence their companies,
to drive their companies
in this direction.
Now, when I say data
leaders, what does that mean?
What is a data leader?
Well, data leaders have lots
of different job titles,
the obvious ones, like Chief
Data Offer, Head of Analytics,
the VP of BI, Data
Analyst, Data Engineer.
But they can also be people
that don't necessarily
have a Data Analytics title
like a Line of Business Leader.
Essentially,
anybody who can help
shape the data strategy
for their organization.
No matter the title,
these are the people
that are tasked with
creating a data culture.
And that means
incorporating data
into not just our work lives
but also our personal lives.
So you can see the examples
of these modern businesses
that I shared.
These data leaders
are the ones who are
driving the company forward.
And that leads us to this idea
that data leadership today
really is business leadership.
So the key is to
find new use cases
for data, use cases
that fall outside
of the conventional
understanding of BI.
This is a very interesting
quote from Forrester
that talks about how leading
companies are thinking
about data and how
they are driving growth
through differentiating
experiences, products,
and services.
Experiences, products,
and services--
it's really interesting.
And what I find fascinating
about this quote
is that it talks about the
value that data can provide,
but nowhere does it use terms
like analytics or reporting
or dashboards.
And the idea is that data
is no longer something that
is used exclusively for
the purpose of analyzing it
on charts and graphs.
Data is now something
that can be infused
into everyday business
processes that
can fuel operational workflows.
It can be used to build
new products to market.
It can used to make
people smarter,
to optimize your operations,
to create new revenue streams.
And this is very
exciting, because what
we're talking about is expanding
the idea of traditional BI
and really bringing it into
the modern era, the era
of data-driven experiences.
So what can you do
as a data leader
to initiate this change
within your organization
and to bring your
company into this era
of data-driven experiences?
Well, first of all, think
of modern data technologies.
Think of your current
technology stack.
What are the technologies
that comprise it?
Think of your business users.
Do they trust the insights
that are delivered by your data
platforms?
Are these insights real-time?
Understanding the data
technologies landscape
is obviously fundamental
for data leaders,
but not just to maintain
technical parity,
but also to be able to
innovate and deliver
cutting-edge solutions using
these modern data technologies.
If you're a younger
organization,
there's a good chance that
you're already digital,
that you're already
cloud-native.
But if you're a more
established business,
and maybe it's been a longer
road to migrate to the cloud
and migrate to
modern technologies,
you need to start this digital
transformation somewhere.
Where do you start?
Choose a department.
Choose a team.
Choose a particular project
to start getting technologies
and people in place.
The key really is to find the
right use case and go after it.
Secondly, imagine new
experiences with data.
As I said before, data is no
longer meant as something just
to be analyzed.
It's really something
that is meant
to lower the barriers for users,
to fuel operational workflows,
to deliver superior
experiences for your employees,
for your customers.
The founder of
Looker, Lloyd Tabb,
has this very powerful
guiding principle
that says that great software
is an act of empathy.
What this means
is it means being
aware of how users use
technology today, of what tools
you're using today.
And meeting them with
data in those tools,
it means meeting our
workforce and customers where
they already work, and bringing
trustworthy data into the tools
that they already use
and they already trust.
And finally, consider
a new role for you.
Data leaders have an
amazing opportunity today
to really influence
the direction
of their organizations
in very significant ways.
Every part of an
organization that's
going through a
digital transformation
is really fueled by
data in some way.
And data professionals who are
capable of not just solving
technology problems, but also
solving business problems
by using data to
create new products,
to discover new value
streams, have become
immensely, immensely valuable.
And we see this within our
own customer base, too,
all the time.
We see data leaders who
have really delivered value
to their organization
and have moved
on to business leadership.
And really, the idea
is that data leaders
are positioned to be the
business leaders of our time.
So what that means,
and to say it
in a very lighthearted way, is
that the data nerds have won.
Data has been infused
into so many moments
of our daily lives--
at work, at home.
And these data experiences are
brought to us by data leaders.
Yes, engineers and analysts,
but also, as I said,
data-savvy marketing people,
salespeople, product people.
All of them are data nerds, and
all of them are data leaders.
And as I mentioned, we see
this within our own customers.
We have a lot of examples
of data-savvy individuals
who were able to rapidly
advance their careers because
of the value that they created
for their organizations,
for their customers
through the use of data.
We have customers, folks,
who were data analysts
just a few years ago.
But they became
highly recruitable
and are now in key
business leadership
positions at their organizations
or other organizations.
So to wrap up, I
hope you recognize
the enormous opportunity
in front of you today--
both from your company,
but also for your career.
Data is more valuable than ever.
And people who can find
a way to lead with data
are in high demand.
We're seeing more
demand than ever
from that data-hungry workforce
and from a customer base.
We see more and more
data that's being
generated by an explosion
of SAS applications.
And we continue to see
data infrastructure
evolving and creating new
possibilities for using data
in ways that were just
unimaginable not that long ago.
So with that, I
want to thank you
for your time and attention.
And I invite you to
learn more about Looker
and engage with our team so
that we can discuss your data
and analytics objectives.
Thank you.